you got a chance
to talk with joe rogan yesterday yes i
did
and i just saw the episode was released
and
uh ivermectin is trending on twitter
joe told me it was an incredible
conversation i look forward to listening
today many people
have probably by the time this is
released i've already listened to it
i think it would be interesting to
discuss
uh a postmortem how do you feel how that
conversation went
and maybe broadly how do you see the
story
as it's unfolding of ivermectin from
the origins from before covert 19
through 2020 to today i very much
enjoyed talking to joe and i'm
uh indescribably
grateful that he would take the risk of
such a discussion
that he would as he described it do an
emergency podcast on the subject
which i i think that was not an
exaggeration this needed to happen
for various reasons that he uh
he took us down the road of talking
about the censorship campaign against
ivermectin which i find
utterly shocking and talking about
the drug itself and i should say we
talked we had pierre corey
available he came on the podcast as well
he is of course the face of the
fl triple c the front line covet 19
critical care
alliance these are doctors who have
innovated
uh ways of treating covet patients and
they happened on ivermectin
and have um been using it and
i hesitate to use the word advocating
for it because that's not really the
role
of doctors or scientists but they are
advocating for it in the sense that
there is this
uh pressure not to talk about its
effectiveness for reasons that we can
go into so maybe step back and say what
is
ivermectin and how much
studies have been done to show its
effectiveness
so ivermectin is an interesting drug it
was discovered
in the 70s by a japanese scientist
named satoshi omura and he found it
in soil near a japanese golf course
so i would just point out in passing
that if we were to stop
self-silencing over the possibility that
asians will be demonized over the
possible lab leak in wuhan
and to recognize that actually the
natural course of the story
has a likely lab leak in china
it has a unlikely hero
in japan the story
is naturally not a simple one but in any
case
uh amura discovered this molecule
he uh sent it to a friend who was at
merck a scientist named campbell they
won
a nobel prize for the discovery of
the ivermectin molecule in 2015
its initial use was in treating
parasitic infections
it's very effective in treating the
the worm that causes river blindness the
pathogen that causes elephantitis
scabies
it's a very effective anti-parasite drug
it's extremely safe it's on the who's
list
of essential medications it's safe for
children it has been administered
something like four billion times in the
last
four decades it has been given away in
the millions of doses
by merck in africa people have
been on it for long periods of time and
in fact one of the
reasons that africa may have had less
severe impacts from covid19 is that
ivermectin
is widely used there to prevent
parasites and the drug appears to have a
long lasting impact so
it's an interesting molecule it was
discovered
some time ago apparently that it has
antiviral properties and so it was
tested
in early in the covet 19 pandemic to see
if it might work
to treat humans with covid it turned out
to have
very promising evidence that it did
treat
humans it was tested in tissues it was
tested at a very high dosage which
confuses people they think that those of
us
who believe that ivermectin might be
useful
in confronting this disease are
advocating those high doses which is not
the case
but in any case there have been quite a
number of studies
a wonderful meta-analysis was finally
released we had seen it in pre-print
version but it was finally
peer-reviewed and published this last
week
it reveals that the drug as clinicians
have been telling us those who've been
using it it's highly effective at
treating people with the disease
especially if you get to them early
and it showed an 86 effectiveness as a
prophylactic to prevent people from
contracting
covid and that number 86 percent
is high enough to drive sars kovi ii
to extinction if we wish to deploy it
first of all the the the meta-analysis
is this the uh ivermectificon19
real-time meta-analysis of 60 studies
or there's a bunch of meta-analysis
there because i i was really impressed
by the real-time meta-analysis that
keeps getting
updated i don't know if it's the same
the one at
ivm meta dot com
well i saw it it's uh c19 ever met yeah
um no this is not that meta analysis so
that is as you say a living meta
analysis where you can watch as
evidence which is super cool by the way
it's really cool and they've got some
really nice graphics that allow you to
understand well what is the evidence you
know
it's concentrated around this level of
effectiveness etc so anyway it's great
site well worth paying attention to
no this is a meta-analysis i don't know
any of the authors but
one second author is tess laurie of the
bird group
bird being a a group of
analysts and doctors in britain that is
playing a role similar to the fl triple
c
here in the u.s um so anyway this is a
meta analysis that that
uh that uh test laurie and others
did of all of the available evidence and
um it's quite compelling people if
people can look for it on my twitter i
will i will put it up and people can
find it there
so what about those here that
in terms of safety what do we understand
about the the kind of dose required to
to have that level of effectiveness and
what do we understand about is
the safety of that kind of dose so let
me just say i'm not a medical doctor
i'm a biologist uh i'm on ivermectin
in lieu of vaccination in terms of
dosage there is one reason for concern
which is that the most effective dose
for prophylaxis
involves something like weekly
administration
that that is because that is not a
historical pattern of use
for the drug um it is possible that
there is some long-term implication of
being on it
for uh being on it weekly for a long
period of time
there's not a strong indication of that
the safety signal that we have
over people using the drug over many
years and using it in high doses in fact
dr corey told me yesterday that
there are cases in which people have
made calculation errors and taken a
massive overdose of the drug and had no
ill effect
so anyway there's lots of reasons to
think the drug is comparatively safe but
no drug is perfectly safe
and i do worry about the long-term
implications of taking it
i also think it's very likely
because the drug is administered
in a dose something like let's say
15 milligrams for somebody my size once
a week after you've gone through the
initial
the initial double dose that you take 48
hours apart
it is apparent that if the amount of
drug
in your system is sufficient to be
protective at the end of the week then
it was probably far
too high at the beginning of the week so
there's a question about whether or not
you could flatten out the intake so that
the amount of ivermectin goes down but
the protection remains i have
little doubt that that would be
discovered if we looked for it
but that said it does seem to be quite
safe
highly effective at preventing kovid the
86 percent number is plenty high enough
for us to drive uh sarsko v2 to
extinction in light of its r
naught number of slightly more than two
um and so why we are not using it as a
bit of a
a mystery so even if everything you said
now
turns out to be not correct
it is nevertheless obvious that it's
sufficiently promising it always has
been
in order to merit rigorous scientific
exploration investigation doing a lot of
studies
and certainly not censoring the science
or the discussion of it
you